[Music]
no I never heard that that's a terrible
theory that's insane
listen up friends fans over the years
there have been plenty of fan theories
out there about our favorite Central
Perk crew
so when Ichi caught up with series
co-creator Marta Kauffman at the ATX TV
festival we had to ask her about the
most shocking one of all I'm curious to
know if you've ever heard the friends
theory about Phoebe that all of the
Friends storylines just took place in
Phoebe's mind and that she just never
actually made any friends that's the
saddest thing I've ever heard the
saddest thing I've ever heard and so I'm
glad that you never heard that theory no
I never heard that that's a terrible
theory that's insane that's crazy like
alt television theory Wow sorry to bring
you down that's me I just think that
someone needs a life someone needs a
life that's all I'm saying that is brand
new information friends holds up so much
to this day why do you feel like that is
oh my god I wish I could claim credit my
hope is that the answer is the stories
were universal they were characters that
you wanted to spend time with TV comes
into your home it's very intimate you
know you watch it when you're in your
robe and and when you're in your bed and
when you're in your PJs and while you're
folding towels and it's intimate so
characters that you would like to have
in your home I think those are the ones
you develop the best relationships with
yeah
[Music]